hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons ya know
you can for some you see your patreon
you're doing good you know listen
there's no middle ground in New York you
either go big or it is what you know
yeah yeah there is like are we
podcasting it we're on we're on right
now this Tim Billy Ghana's Papa
strictest Evernote egg - this is going
out yeah yeah so everybody behave you
think it's going this kid when your
producer what's his name ray will bad
when he opened the door most kissed him
right on the list yeah I mean this could
open the door and I said is this my
Grindr date I understand why Sal Vulcano
wants to get inside you yeah I mean it
was awkward Sal stop the episode was
like this guy's a hottie you know I love
it sounds like he's I could get a boy I
get a model I said he's gonna do it's
gonna be an audio engineer yeah let's
make a right turn so we can release this
deal your first your last hotel room
that we just [ __ ] I said was 9/11 9/11
9/11 in the Carlile now your hotel room
is 2001 2000 I don't know what that
means but I think you had something to
do with [ __ ] 9/11 very interesting
you're absolutely right about that it's
something there's something odd about
that 9/11 and the 2001 that's [ __ ]
creep it's weird it's almost like the
government is following you and they
just decided we were gonna do a video on
Epstein's Island we just decided not to
yeah I thought about it I just thought
about I said you know what why poke the
bear no here's it really gonna nothing's
gonna happen to you you don't know
that's didn't know that the guys who the
Secret Service agents or whatever
[ __ ] NSA people are listening to your
podcast or whatever they love it
right so it's like it just not gonna do
anything I mean they enjoy when you say
that yeah when you said I was sitting in
Long Island with a mound of coke and a
car saying we need to listen to Rush
Limbaugh saying we need to honor our
contract to the people of Iraq that will
go like this guy is
no we're sorry boss but it's cuz we're
protecting him yeah we need him this guy
yeah but we we were gonna do a video my
friend works in the Virgin Islands we're
gonna do a video we're gonna roll up to
FC's island and just hop off right and
do a little video in front of that
temple where god only knows what he was
doing in there this kids get married in
five months yeah some other kid wants to
come and film I said I can't lead these
[ __ ] kids wait a second did you get a
call from his mom like like in the movie
almost famous oh you're the dawn like
just make sure my son is safe I don't
know what you're doing with your rock
star lifestyle but yeah can't bring my
son to Epstein's I mean yeah I know I
work I didn't but I just didn't wanna
like watch him get pushed off a cliff by
a groundskeeper on Epstein's Island and
then have to [ __ ] go tell his fiancee
like I'm sorry he was great he was a
great editor yeah he really understood
what i was about comedic ly and here's
the other thing I don't want to believe
that the world is run by pedophiles but
let's be honest there's harder things to
prove harder things to disprove than
that yeah right you you would have a
real hard time proving that that wasn't
at least partially true yeah so about
something happens when you climb up the
ladder of power yeah that just sort of
unlocks a very dark sexual loss
something's there that's copy level of
Mario Brothers well yeah and it's like
you get there and it's not a princess
it's just like a legal noodles what
excites you anymore right know what I
mean like you've done everything what
you've done it like I know for a fact
when John Travolta
first started to become famous or he was
just having sex with women and then he
had sex with all the women and then it
started to be like only guys are gonna
excite me and I'm gonna be honest with
you Tim I'm getting close right I'm
getting close that level till you [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] I talking a lot of time
with slowed it down
well yeah chlamydia slowed it then right
Jesus intervened took the wheel it was
trippy but I feel good yeah so I have to
slow it down a choice but my point is is
that if you gave a guy like me I'm a
nice person
I vote and told by my peers I'm a nice
person I love you know my daughter I
love God but if you gave me hundreds of
millions of dollars and gave me this
power it's a real problem I may start to
do things like Yanis was commenting on
how beautiful the horses we saw a horse
walking by because we're in fighting he
said don't you think now you can see how
easy it is for a person to get attracted
to a horse yeah and I said absolutely
not Chris because I see so much [ __ ] in
so much Latina asked and I'm like what
about the horse I'd like the horse right
right yes I'm looking at you read
without you keep [ __ ] tickling that
mustache it's gonna get ya did he know
your fiance yeah you're gonna get a load
on your back that's why a OC is right
she's right now Mao Stalin AOC there all
right yeah nobody should put that much
money or power
yeah he'll see the Stalin in the corners
I'd knock him down a little bit we need
to take a little bit of the money yeah
we need to take a little bit of money
yeah you gotta [ __ ] kids in a hotel room
2001 at the Manhattan clubs because this
carpets disgusting I think on that
stairs starts screaming going what is
good to people come in and jerk off on
the carpet when I'm out yeah something's
going on this place smells like a hostel
yeah it's not not use a buck forty and
night yeah and uh that's crazy that
Midtown is that cheap it's cheap
downtown is where the big project is
well yes four managers are bringing
their harems yeah they used to be up
here now Chinese businessmen used to be
up here yeah no no they're downtown and
I'm up here podcasting is going on yeah
yeah yeah confuse Norwegian Taurus yeah
right now yeah so like I'm here for a
bit I'm here for like a ten day thing
it's like you got you got to try to stay
under 200 we're gonna be here today so
stay with your family on Long Island you
just you don't want to deal with their
boomers and their [ __ ] out there
complaining about something I mean
they're complaining about inheriting
houses yeah
where my family's had yeah they're
inheriting homes and they can't handle
it because they got to renovate them yes
much of a project yeah you get over 30
you cannot stay with your family you can
barely stay with friends unless they're
very wealthy right I'd have like a wing
of their house can you're over 30 the
sleepovers are done
I wake up with crippling anxiety like
we're all crazy right
wake up and somebody else is [ __ ]
home at 2:00 a.m. I'm like oh god yeah I
go to sleep at 3:00 a.m. just so I know
my first wake up with anxiety is during
the day yet so I can go right right to
bed yeah I can't wake up at 1:30 with
anxiety outs at the dark yes I go to bed
at 2:30 every night I wake up at like
5:30 I'm like what the day's almost here
today the Sun will save us and then I go
back to bed for another four hours
Christ can't be in somebody else's home
yeah no my family's at my house right
now for Christmas I mean and it's it's
it's a little like a honest I'm in rare
form because I've been off I've been off
women now for a month I've been celibate
on a month and already it's like the
anxiety I've been like I got a text
girls I got a text girls but I've just
bought Eckart Tolle but tell me called I
bring the power of now by Eckhart Tolle
beautiful and I'm being friendly with my
present but that also includes at times
like to get the anxiety out I can't have
sex with women so I went down to Shore
Road in Bay Ridge and I yelled racial
slurs at the water family we'll just say
those racial slurs very calmly on their
couch this is very sweet and this is
what I love about boomers in Long Island
right one more time
boom a baby boomer okay they were but
they were born after World War two when
we needed to replenish the population
and people started pushing out people
they believed and you know the suburban
home suburbs were invented so host
boomer when America went downhill was
after World War two even when you get
real estate everyone asks is this a
pre-war building because they made [ __ ]
good then right after World War two they
just threw up cardboard boxes to sell an
American dream
that doesn't exist right now and it's in
Long Island is like the paradise of of
that dream it's like a microcosm of what
it looks like all across the country
it's a disaster
it's strip malls it's Panera bread's
it's holding buzzers to get tables at
dinner and Outback Steakhouse
it's all
there's nothing good about yeah and
that's by the way those are the positive
qualities the negative qualities are my
football coach [ __ ] me yeah I'm on
heroin right now I'm not like but your
mother's a boomer but she's a city kid
right she's born and raised Queens New
York different listen yeah true boomer
to me and this is this means nothing
it's just my own the weight my concept
of them in the mind is the suburbs so
true boomer like if you're in New York
or Queens or Brooklyn or even like if
you're in LA to an extent even though
it's the suburbs or if you live in
Chicago yes you're still a boomer but to
me the real boomer experience is the
suburbs yeah your parents moved out of a
city
your grandparents probably grew up in a
city they got out they live in the
suburbs you stayed in the suburbs I were
raised in the shop by the way it was all
a mark the modern American Dream was all
a marketing ploy by the auto lobby right
and they capitalized on the white need
to stay away from minorities right and
then sure and then their kids realized
oh no the minorities were all the
funnest right when you sit in an
Applebee's bar right and like you know
and journey comes on rye and why people
start swaying yeah you want to put a gun
in the club yeah where's q-tip DJ yeah I
applaud the Millennials who are moving
back yes just get rid of the walk Ness
right get rid of the walk is you can
walk for so long you starting to [ __ ]
hallucinate right time to take a nap
take a nap go to sleep well we what's
interesting about women aren't women
yeah you understand
you hate to make a sacrifice Yeah right
do what you want to do right if you
think jerking off above this pull-out
couch when you're sleeping you got
another thing coming ray when you wake
up and your lips are a little whiz you
on my show them Italians - Irish women
or - yes
too much of anything is not a good it's
not good it's just a over low but the
Boomers really it's the 50s and 60s is
when they were they had like my dad is a
tactical boomer yeah that was born in
1952 yeah came up during the whole
hippie Woodstock was in a band and then
turned around and all the sudden he's
selling office equipment for Pitney
Bowes yeah by the way that's part of it
is what we that's what we need we sell
millenia because the millennial
generation is kind of like the boomer
generation the war is over it is a big
peacetime there's prosperity right they
got all these ideals there's like deal
ISM they're holding signs no it's like
we need that generation you just realize
it's time yeah to get a job you can't do
as much the comedy and forever you have
to do something my dad didn't like his
job but that's okay he wasn't good at it
and he came home every day and he laid
on the couch to watch Sally Jessy
Raphael or whatever the hell was on TV
or just he did what he had to do to race
me he wasn't thrilled about it and my
mother was a Weeki Wachee mermaid in
florida you want to talk about real
serious jobs which she would swim around
in the tank and truckers would jerk off
because the strip clubs weren't open yet
yeah it was yeah so this is how
seriously that yeah and that might be
Frank Sinatra yeah
your father if your father had another
kids in that generation whose father
might be Frank Sinatra off your horse oh
yeah no but it's like if your father has
enough energy like now all these fathers
have energy because they're not working
it's like our dad said couldn't because
they were [ __ ] exhausted we do and
share they couldn't play with me so I
had to learn myself I learned how to
play basketball do things like that
myself yeah you know well my father's
different could use a criminal but a lot
of fathers he's still work job whatever
you collect all the pin numbers are and
yeah count numbers yeah to steal the
money cuz you tell the sons comedy money
is it cleaned out your mom's account -
absolutely clean kid likes to put a
little money on horses horses it's what
it's you know what can you do is what
happened to them like you know one
picture was my dad at Woodstock and it
was not quite at Woodstock but at one of
those day and then the next picture was
he's like in an ill-fitting suit yeah
trying to knock over small businesses
and some copiers you know it's just
that's what it was a really a capsule HD
generation of boomers they grew up
listening to Bob Dylan right smoke and
weed trying to find the third eye
speaking about world peace and how Viet
Nam's are paradise right and then it
just kind of ended with them screaming
about ms-13 right there yes it's always
13 whether we're being invaded by ms-13
it's a perpetual culture of victimhood
like they're the original victims yeah
people don't understand how to
Millennials gap you know how the
Millennials become victims the boomers
are the original victims yeah they're
the people that got they inherited the
money they got the cheap loans to cheap
credit they got the GI Bill
well not that you hypo but they got to
run off of the GI Bill which was the big
inherited house Long Island Levittown
everything but they still disco cards
have been stacked against them somehow
yeah somehow someway my parents why
can't my father always says the same
three things in perpetuity cuz can't get
ahead yeah can't get ahead he's like the
rose trying to get yeah yeah he's think
I'm just trying to stay out of trouble
and I'm like you like who who's trying
he shot again just trying to get who's
trying to get here need to go play piano
or [ __ ] restaurant who's trying to
get you high father will literally say
he will literally say no matter what you
say to him his response if you say to
him dad I killed a man
here's response will because you know
the older I get the more important I
realize it is to golf
nine holes if you have to just you go
she get to my age you regret it you were
gay he regrets not playing more golf yes
what is regret the suburbs is a mistake
that malls are a mistake it's an
absolute horror show yeah it's it is a
wasteland it's a it's a real corporate
capitalist wasteland yeah by the way I
just want to say hello to all Tim's
friends who are listening you
[ __ ] cocaine on your [ __ ]
ties yeah listen to me
I know our last episode wasn't [ __ ]
funny yeah and I agree with everything
you say in your real people and I
appreciate it cuz you got real sense of
humor but this one's [ __ ] funny you
[ __ ] [ __ ] here the dynamic
changes are too [ __ ] arrogant
[ __ ] two three funny cases every
episode can't be funny you need
something to listen you know while you
wait for your D we lawyer to show up in
a diner yeah okay you can't be chuckling
when your DV lawyer shows up to the
Westbury diner and says so this is
number three reading the local Syosset
eyes on your paper [ __ ] place man cuz
you were a little [ __ ] up and Lily
Flanagan you should have taken an over
but that [ __ ] piss you off and yeah
[ __ ] it I'm in charge of my own destiny
I'm just gonna barrel down the Parkway
that's what it is yeah go get your
[ __ ] sushi at a restaurant this
podcast on it hit the elliptical at Life
Fitness yes once you get out there the
boomer mentality is so pervasive kids
are boomers like nineteen year olds
their favorite musicians Billy Joel
that's ridiculous wild but they don't
modernize yeah it's like when I start to
get into comedy right when I first start
to get a comment this when I start to
meet this new kind of person because
where I grew up in Ridgewood Queens
everybody's kind of like you know
everybody's dad works everybody's dad's
in the Union so it's like my dad's
really worrying around so we're
listening to jay-z
right whatever we're supposed to be you
know even comedy it's like I used to
watch you know Jay Leno with my mom
whatever cuz I slept in the bed when I
was about 16 years old it's what it is
yeah but then it's like I start I
started to feel secure when I first
tried to get into Connolly 2009/2010 all
these kids like you don't know any
Beatles songs you don't you don't know
you don't you've never heard a Lenny
Bruce it's like yep my dad was a real
guy
you know my mom's a real person it's
like yeah whew I don't know what you and
your [ __ ] homo dad's are played like
you listen to the Beatles and you're we
were rebellion to me culture was a way
to repel and a way to be like [ __ ] our
parents we want something that's our own
you know and the weird thing about Long
Island is it's a lot of kids that they
want to become their parents that's the
goal they don't want to do better than
their parents like we looked at our
parents we were like okay great but we
want to do something else I'm different
we're [ __ ] wrong we want to do
something else a lot of them we looked
at and we're like you know they're in a
you know maybe they were in a trap or
maybe they're a job that didn't excite
us right look at my dad I'm like he
doesn't like what he does yeah doesn't
like what he does and then and you want
to do something else you wanna kind of
break that cycle and then not everyone
can obviously and you make a lot of
sacrifices too but that's the thing
that's where a lot of these those boomer
ideals and what I love about it and it's
just that Fox News kind of culture of
like we're being invaded
everybody's killing us ms-13 your door
ms-13 the door ready to kill you every
minute so you need you know Tucker
Carlson to keep you safe Donald Trump's
gonna keep you safe from ms-13 yeah yeah
let's see honest if your dad is not
voting for Trump he's pushing the family
in the wrong direction like that I just
want to be on record saying that because
if he's believing in what the left can
do and I'm not I'm a more liberal person
but it's like you want to hope that your
dad like I'm in charge of my family so
the votes going to Trump because I'm
trying to push this thing I'm trying to
give my daughter a future and I know the
acasio Cortes of the world they'll take
it they'll ruin my daughter's life it's
a choice it's a bad choice it's a Brits
a real bad joke well it's just we were
talking last night Tim it's like it's
the same play over and over and over
line it seems now it's Stalin it's this
it's Che Guevara it's it and you know
the thing about the the boomer
generation is when when you take a
course in college on counterculture and
the 60s and things like that American
boomers when they were teenagers
whatever they're they're they're the
heroes of this story they're the heroes
of the story and then there's this other
side on the other side of just these
white men who have crew cuts
who are on the other side holding guns
at the kids holding flowers who were
androgynous all right and it's like
there's a good guy bad guy kind of
fetish fetishization yes of those two
sides that removes all nuance which is
we're kind of the liberal the modern
liberal arts kind of inculcation has
started
yeah it really started with the boomers
yeah saying these are the bad guys
we're the good guys she's a doom these
are the superheroes yeah but it's like
you know what those kids were Crewcuts
did bad things and those kids with long
hair who were endogenous Karen flair is
a bad thing yeah and now you know it's
like my dad would say you know my dad
was in the Korean War and he would say
he would say you know I feel bad for
what happened my dad was because he
fought in a war no wars are good but you
know when my dad was old like the weeks
before his death I wanted I like it hit
me I was like you know what you were
kind of fighting for something good
right look at North Korea now it's right
good right there's something off about
the utopian notion of everyone being
equal because it's ill go look at nature
it's the opposite of nature's a little
bit if you want to survive and succeed
imitate nature nature needs to allow for
something to [ __ ] survive I'm a
capitalist of a libertarian now the
hottest move to the suburb for two weeks
it now gets just walking around he's got
a fascist haircut now really sasshi ya
know he says it's removed nuance and it
started with the boomers and it started
with the counterculture there was a lot
of good losses then they don't look it
but they're fetishize yeah they're
fetishized they also got a look at like
what I think a lot of boomers did was
they just took everything they didn't
think about what was good long term for
anything right everything was about take
it get it buy it consumerism short
mortgage crisis just give me I want more
bigger house bigger pool bigger they are
the most materialistic generation
they're not really religious or
spiritual they don't there's that you
know my grandfather's generation they
had war your father's generation had war
they had honor and valor even those
things that aren't great awards aren't
good but they had other things the
boomer generation is defined to me
almost exclusively by materialism sure
things its houses cars wants needs but
more wants you know cruises a birthday
dinner don't you think actually went
from one extreme to the other yeah they
went from one extreme of like we're
against all that to like total indulging
and yeah the total indulgence is what
leaves you feel empty that's why
everybody in long as working around
trying to shoot up to feel anything
because you know you once you
the pool in a house in the car and
everything else it's empty and I wanted
erna tea leaves you feeling empty and
the boomers have just said well we're
just gonna take another cruise we're
just gonna eat another lavish dinner
we're gonna you know we're gonna go to
another vacation we're gonna go see
Fleetwood Mac again we're gonna go just
it's just over and over again I mean I
remember this is a great boomer moment
my friend's girlfriend got arrested for
impersonating people she was cashing
fake checks she was on Indiana's Most
Wanted
okay yeah Isabel she's not a stripper we
gotta get her on the pot that woman yes
she just gota ten years or her fourth
you in Chicago ten years she's in jail
right now they don't [ __ ] around there
they go you're going in for ten she's
got three kids they're black she's not
is what it is she's fun she's not a
racist
so she but she kind of is also so here's
the other thing she the cops show up at
the house my friend Ryan great kid
choose had answers the door big guy
bigger than you makes you look like a
little twink yeah absolutely heads at
the door - cops goes Isabel here he goes
no he goes let me explain you how this
works he's a state troopers they go we
have extradition or whatever they call
the treaty with like like not treaty but
you know we got to get her out of here
she you know Indiana State Police she's
on the Most Wanted so the reality is we
have a warrant to search this property
to come in here and if we find her in
here you're an accessory now if you
don't tell us where she is right now so
I'm gonna ask you again
where is she then my friend Ryan looked
at the money what she's in the kitchen
so they walk in they take her out and
cuffs everything like that I'm having
dinner at his house that night his
girlfriend that he'd been seeing for two
years Indiana's most wanted just gonna
take it out Dave my friends Ryan's
parents who I love best people in the
world are talking about buying a condo
in Naples was buying a condo in Naples
and would it be near the beach which
should be near to be and it's just like
these it was a generation of people
where was about them yeah it was about
so even the protesting which was about
was supposed to be was about other
people was itself that it's a little
more essentially all about that well I
would see it I see it in right now
Christmastime is coming up when my
grandfather was still alive who was in
his you know he died in his late 70s and
this was in the late 90s but he would
always say because my mother is all
about what Christmas I mean the piles of
presents yes
stress are through the roof but any
temperature control just making a little
cooler little cooler yeah well my
grandpa would always say he would always
be like this isn't what Christmas is
about no with stop with the gift stop
with the gifts get him one thing get one
thing right I always kind of I always
thought about that like now me being a
father and I'm like you know I got my
daughter a couple of gifts we're like my
mother it's like you got to get your
daughter 35 gifts and it's like no
because you're saying that consumerism
that capitalism she was born with that I
really kind of we can see a little bit
better now there's an emptiness to it I
think there's an emptiness you know
because you chant you're just chasing
and then you know you're just chasing
things without meaning and that here
comes the problem like my listen I love
my dad to death he's a good dude
but you know a lot of his life was
defined by the need to have money for
these things well it's a more I think
it's religion - it's the same yeah I
think it's like I said I think it's an
American dream that was marketed to them
after the world war yeah that hey
there's this perfect life when really
the American Dream is the pursuit of of
an of happiness the pursuit if you have
an idea you start a company yeah that's
the real American dream being your own
boss starting something you're creative
right taking it as far as it can go
the American Dream is not the end result
you know hey picket fence car you know
and and market it it was more worried by
the auto lobby who who's really provided
the blueprint for what America now looks
like coast to coast between the old
cities it's all marketing America where
the best marketers and were the best of
condition thinking thinking and it's
been happening from day one of our
country in we've talked about this on
the podcast even the idea of freedom
from the British Empire was just a
marketing ploy to get more troops the
people at the time didn't even want that
in the 1700 they were like no Britain
doesn't really beat the [ __ ] out of us
who they just we just want to be
represented in Parliament but George
Washington and all those guys and
Jefferson were like you know the
marketing strategy here is independence
and be the free nation so we get more
soldiers to sign up but that's not
really what this isn't about yeah the
Nazis put all those choosing
concentration camps as just a marketing
tool to get everybody galvanized you
know
Marketing is there more to marketing
yeah I mean in addition thinking it
seems like shouting by the middle that
middle you know that middle-income
family is it's just being squeezed out I
mean I see people are either elite or
you're struggling in my family and
during the during Thanksgiving or any
holiday that's all my family talks about
because we represent the middle is how
the poor get everything and the rich get
everything and the middle is just
getting [ __ ] the middle let's just
trim the middle does get [ __ ] but on
the flip side again just to just to
remember nuance which I think needs to
come back in our education system I
think the real failure is going on the
educational I think I think it's not
that bad of an idea right now and then
as if you're an 18 or 19 year old kid
listening I think it's not that bad of
idea to leave college I don't know if
how much college helps you number one
nobody cares if you have a degree or not
and all it does is [ __ ] give you
those radical crazy like Old English in
China go through that in your career now
because you it nobody cares if you have
a bachelor's degree right they don't
care well what I was a getting job gonna
have a doctorate yeah yeah what I was
doing I'm still doing podcast with rain
is gay friend the the the middle class
the middle class does get [ __ ] the
middle class is disappearing yeah
flipside you know I had this sort of I
had this sort of exchange as kind of
argument take that a if you will with
this liberal like journalist online and
she was saying this she was saying you
know what Yanis is Twitter is just
watching someone have a breakdown in
real time yeah yeah which is great he's
no more having a breakdown and he says
all the time he says he says I don't
want to put out podcast cuz I don't want
the heat on us and then you look at his
Twitter and it's like what the [ __ ] all
trace are you all you're doing is what
are you doing he's fine fine it's 3:00
a.m. and I'm on the toilet I'm watching
Yanis and Seth Simon's fighting chiding
oh yeah I'm like what you suit so we got
a push back we got to hold the line boys
that's what we doubt hash tag Yanni long
days because I know when I see those
pleats I'm like I'm the one who's across
the front of it yeah happy you're in a
fight with a journalist no journalist
and she's saying all these things and
there's truth to that yes yes I mean
we become increasingly you know top
teller level or or for a lot of us but
in America poor doesn't mean poor yeah
that's the other thing it's like she was
she she said we're becoming like like um
what's the dubai she says like Dubai I
go wait a second yeah we're not there's
no indentured servitude happening yeah
there's no South Asian being used by oil
money Arabs to [ __ ] build high-rises
right that's not happening the poor
people here are eating meat for a dollar
right I mean they all got homes they got
phones right people here have a phone
they're the internet it's like so yeah
the middle class of money she's paying
for their welfare right yeah so that's
spoiled culture and a little bit of a
way because how much better do you want
it
compared to what like I wanna ask these
protesters compare there you go this is
my this country that's compared to what
Grace's country go out to it we are the
least racist country at this you yell
racial slurs in public at the soccer
game yeah you're a match the [ __ ]
they like to they like to [ __ ]
lecture us and then you watch a soccer
game and there's just a whole section
doing a Nazi salute right
there's no that's the Conservative Party
nobody would do that throw bananas on
the [ __ ] field there it is a little
worse there it is a little worse there
but I do think that people are
frustrated with with with how much rich
people have gotten away with I think
that's fair I think it's fair to be
frustrated by how much rich people have
gotten away with ok communist Martin on
next week these guys are out of control
that's the you're gonna have to bring a
be on to [ __ ] what capitalism isn't
fair that way but I mean what do you
want do you want it to go back to
socialism is it's not capitalism it's
not what we're living in is not
capitalism it's institutionalized
criminality we're have to set in
Congress are blackmailed by [ __ ] guys
on islands photographing them have sex
with kids and then they have to go vote
for whatever the [ __ ] big business wants
it's not capitalism it's gangsters
international gangsters this is not
capitalism these buildings are owned by
a Russian oligarchs in Chinese amusement
park like well that are taking all this
has nothing to do with Adam Smith
capitalism this is
everything to do with crime cabal's of
criminals enriching themselves who are
not doing anything democratically none
of this shit's being voted on it's all
being [ __ ] shoved down people's
throats nobody votes on this year why do
you think the biggest proponents of
immigration are on the right they're on
the right it's into Koch brothers it's a
Chamber of Commerce all these big
business guys want to pay these people a
dollar so that they don't have to hire
black people and they don't have to hire
people that are low-income in America so
what you see is I you know these
immigration raids are cruel and they
suck and I don't like what Isis doing
but what happens is when you have these
immigration rates African unemployment
african-american unemployment drops
people that are poor in that area then
go work in these factories that we're
all so I think there's a it I I don't
want communism I don't want any type of
collectivism but we do have to rot like
the Donald Trump's the result of the
system that's been rotted out
that people have no faith in anymore and
they're not wrong to not have any faith
in it they're not wrong to not have any
faith in the system
with the President of the United States
can fly to a pedophile island 26 times
and then the guy whose island it is gets
killed in jail instead of being held
accountable and none of his accomplices
were ever held accountable so they're
not wrong to lose faith in that type of
system you know but I don't but do you
really believe that that will change or
can change I don't know but I I think
the frustration is natural and
understandable the idea that you have a
system that is completely for one group
of people that rich people can buy their
way out of prison they can buy their
kids way out of getting caught with
drugs I mean up until recently if you
were smoking a joint on 125th Street you
were going to jail for three years and
you're gonna have a felony conviction
and you know that's because potentially
in the private prisons is gonna say the
private prison that they're trying to
get you placed at a low cost that's make
tonight realities you have all this
slave labor that's what is that earn
daddys modern-day slavery Cortez is
annoying she doesn't have any power I
think you gotta get off Twitter and you
realize that people I could cost you
Cortes they don't have any [ __ ] power
although no one got their well with who
Jimmy Fallon the reality is the guys
that have power are still the people
that want to sell water and air to you
that's the progress Mike
question do you really think it's what's
your evidence beyond like beyond theory
yeah beyond theorize yeah what's your
evidence that this is widespread in the
norm what's what do you like Epstein and
what was going on with you know it is is
a particular story about Epstein well
let's say it wit me Norman watch you're
not everyone is touching kids no no one
search almost all of them are touching
kids
yeah but not everyone say Kevin studies
I'm saying that when you look at the
ability of wealthy people to evade
justice that's that that's the oldest
story in the book job of this authority
if it was your kid it's not a good story
it's not a good story my kid and I'm
Richard he gets off it's a very good
story you know what I'm saying here the
reality is if it's someone that you know
if it's a kid that's being abused by
somebody who's able to do it with
impunity it's it's it's a very big
problem it's also a very big problem if
if people are blackmailing politicians
like you all these debates we're having
and supposedly this good good-faith
debates about a system that people go in
there and say hey I think it should be
this another guys I think it should be
this let's mean the middle it's
compromise let's make laws if you go in
there and you're [ __ ] owned and
blackmailed and you you're just not even
representing the people in your district
anymore you're doing whatever the
[ __ ] corporation or whoever says you
should do because they have power on you
and it doesn't have to be sexual
blackmail it could be financial
blackmail with anything but Timmy okay
and I raised a perfect example yeah okay
because they they lean on all these
politicians right they're a powerful
lobby yeah and a younger me would go you
know what NRA is evil enter raise they
look and then you go to these places you
go to these places these districts that
we're speaking of and the people right
that's what they want right that's the
way they vote they don't live in a city
where everyone's living on top of each
other they watch Fox News and they're
paranoid about ms-13 Ryan T Indiana
democracy so I'm sure the are they more
are they are they brainwashed are they
marketed to meaning so who wants the
carried interest loophole on Wall Street
who wants that who voted for that who
voted for the idea that
people could come into New York City
with shell corpse and just buy ten
apartments with blood money because they
poisoned a river in zambia and
essentially can be freedom baby cominjee
freedom bought it but it's not it's not
your name right no you're not you know
creative creative it you create a crime
bro that's crime that's why you have a
Donald respect it's why you have you
gotta start doing more I know the less
annoying I hate the left is my as much
as anybody but it it comes from
somewhere this all comes with Donald
Trump this comes from someone by the way
Donald Trump comes from the left yeah
he's traditionally his whole life until
recently it was answer and he even he
even knew that the economy works better
with a little with a little regulations
as it balances things out that's it but
it the whole thing is if you get cancer
and you have to declare bankruptcy and
and that becomes a problem people give
people if you're if you're rationing
your insulin but let's so that you can
live yeah while you know people the
Kardashians are worth a hundred billion
dollars and their main export is lip
gloss Tyson on and when he just told us
if Jeff Bezos was able to lay all his
money in dollar bills in a line he would
have enough money to get from the earth
to moon and back sixteen times
wrap it around earth two hundred times
and then the with the money left over be
able to like go to Australia some could
line up all his money on the floor a
large percentage event we're gonna pay
off women I understand we're saying so
then that can happen there and yeah I
don't even know anything about Jeff
Bezos how he uses a human being but if
that's the case then yeah there
shouldn't be people having a rat's ass
and this is where we all come back
together because at the end of the day a
lot of these things aren't political the
salute the problems are very deep and
the solutions will be maybe yeah they've
kind of come from technology or science
or whatever a lot of these problems are
like the system is kind of broken
Facebook I think is worth how many
billions of dollars been you can look
that up it's it trillions beans at all
they employ like forty thousand people
you know
GM at its height employed millions of
millions of billions of people these
companies that are now generating as
much more wealth are now all there why
would you believe how many people they
employ well they employ it because it's
although everything's being made
overseas doesn't have its of course but
I think my future is scary for the
American worker if you're a worker right
now the futures need are scary that's
why that's wanting people to employ
thirty five thousand five hundred
billion thirty five thousand people
that's why when you watch when you watch
these Democratic debates you'll stand a
guy like Andrew yang say we need a
national income right that's what we
need we need a national income the
glaciers are melting there's gonna be no
more jobs and nobody the crowd doesn't
even clap cuz that's boring because it's
true but then you'll have another person
say well I want to clean the White House
because Trump's a pig and they get an
applause break right you're doing it to
yourself yeah want to choose a side
either the people are the problem it's
like people or the people problem
because nobody wants to live in the gray
area and the gray areas where most
people live I'm a it's like yes I want
free health care for everyone because I
believe in your in just yeah but you
know what else I want the [ __ ] wall
because I get the wall does that will
win ya wall and health care wins yeah
immigration policy and health care win
I'm not saying I want I don't know they
just want immigrants to come in this is
beautiful more the country yeah but they
need to be vetted you know what I mean
well listen Donald Trump is right if you
want your health care which we should
have I'm for single-payer health care
you know you got it you got a look at
you got to look in the world
we're the ones fighting evil is that
Netherlands time for you send more than
just a food truck when we go yeah you
know it's you're like all the countries
yeah that have health care they're able
to have health care because we go fight
their Wars and they send [ __ ] food
truck we're fighting we need oil is why
we need oil we need to be making a lot
of money yeah so I agree with you 100%
the issue now is you really can't it's
hard to de-escalate from where we are my
point it's hard to guess cliff why would
you want to de-escalate baby we're wrong
just enjoy your Roman citizens enjoy the
end look at what's really happening it's
the end if yeah there's no solution
right what we're doing here is just
killing time to make money off doing
nothing that's why that's just
no jobs left we're just smart enough and
[ __ ] criminal enough right to [ __ ]
steal money from these people on patreon
this is not a real job right we're just
charismatic and we're winning none of
this is productive it's over right house
rains and that's the way it should be
CEO strongest [ __ ] to survive in the
week should diet disease shuttle is oh
the only thing stronger than all I don't
believe on this podcast I'm just trying
to make it entertaining cuz Tim's friend
said the last one was too [ __ ] hairy
yeah my friend socks he he went to that
restaurant Don and Jeannie was like oh
it was okay
who goes him and did some Vietnamese
fishwife he's dating they go to Don ng
and they [ __ ] Ted then they go offer
to bring me leftovers I'm like you gonna
bring me a cake you don't know anything
that restaurants [ __ ] great you big
nose [ __ ] he's got a big nose you know
GBD I think we should do it CB I think
we should make weed illegal put them all
back in jail what I think all these
[ __ ] tak [ __ ] bros running around
la trying to figure out a way to deliver
you weed on a [ __ ] scooter they shall
go right back to Rikers him you know
it's over I don't over I know it's how
would it can't go quicker now things
can't change their heart yeah we are an
object falling to the ground picking up
speed the closer we you know here's the
fish over I didn't know the end would be
this hilarious it's great that's what no
one thought yeah no one thought the end
would be like a Family Guy episode
nobody imagined the end would be Donald
try game show host and and a classic
quick test was a bartender yeah six
months ago somebody gave her a book on
Marxism and now she's like yeah
political Savior of the country yeah
nobody knew how kind of hilarious this
would be Socrates did yeah you go back
to the Republican say democracy the
longer it goes on
yep the the the the older people start
to pander to the younger people that
have to act like when everything's okay
number one he said in the book
everything was okay look at it now all
Kasich Oh Chaz knows better than some
seven-year-old he says look at old
people like they're pathetic their life
experiences cynicism right no that's
called wisdom
you young [ __ ] you write the vessel of a
human here's what Socrates said he said
here's the example and here's how you
know it's gonna be over I said what
you're gonna start to see him s13 is
gonna be everywhere Muslims everywhere
yeah what he said no he said he said two
things he said when one everything is
okay like Jana said cuz he's don't
forget at the height of ancient Rome
right start to crumble and I'm all for
it - yeah I love everybody but it's like
you could do whatever you want orgies in
the streets homosexuality everywhere
there were no rules anymore you couldn't
say anything nobody cared right so
that's one woman was a man a man was a
woman whatever you want to say that was
her own was as liberal as modern-day
West Village right now that's the truth
yeah and then what also he said he said
that you're gonna start to see once
democracy that the fundamental problem
with democracy is not everyone's
supposed to be voted he said you should
go to school to vote you should get it
you should you should go only specific
parts of the democracy should be elected
to the top to even vote the minute you
give everybody the right to vote what's
gonna happen is this since what's
happening now is you're gonna have a
candy shop owner and a doctor and the
doctors gonna say candy is bad for you
so you know Candy's bad for you but I'm
telling you live longer if you vote for
me they're gonna say [ __ ] you and the
candy shop owner is gonna say I'll give
you all the candy you want just vote for
me and the candy shop owner will get
elected yeah that's what's happening is
the candy shop owner I called Plato's
getting elected because he was saying
you need to go to school like your major
in college should be voting and then we
can at least have a better idea of
trusting but this overall idea that
everybody's got the same vote it's
stupid and he said it's it's why he
didn't believe in democracy
you know Greece they abandoned democracy
for a long time if they invented it but
they didn't use it for a thousand years
well we're not even really a democracy
we're not a democracy
the my personal belief first of all I
just want all Ulysses to know I'm a
liberal kid it's just by the way yeah
the idea that anyone believes that at
this point is the funniest thing oh by
the way that's of me sitting in a chair
and be like I just want anybody to know
I'm a vegetarian every photo every photo
and video depiction of me has been
insane
every song of me eating a rib I too am
at Smith of olinsky's is a lie I'm a
vegetable kid and you can see my ribs
yeah here's a I'm also a liberal here by
the way if you don't know it's a network
on television your house you put your
blazer on conservative kids are more
open-minded the liberal kids yeah well
the liberal kids are also boring
yeah that's an open-minded you know the
head open-minded now and they're boring
and the problem is if fanatics look
malnourished something into their skulls
yeah they're all have roommates it's
like that's not what I want I want serve
the kids with the money who are doing
things on their own right so uh Plato's
Republic
you know Plato was advocating for a
class of people called philosopher kings
this is common you know one-on-one
philosophy [ __ ] but yeah it's kind of
true when you think about it like I I
think the a bicameral or tri cameral
representative body is a good idea so
right government by the people so every
district every whatever has their
representative that that interacts with
these philosopher kings or this judicial
branch to point on how you do it but the
president that branch the executive
branch that he's elected you know with
all this money like you're talking about
cuz obviously that's the problem is the
money that's the part where you're going
like maybe Plato was right maybe that
guy needed to be a philosopher king
somebody who who is trained or watched
by a body like a Yoda or something to be
that he's in for four to six years but
he's not just some [ __ ] game show
host that has charisma
maybe that guy needs to be tested for
his morality for that exactly can't
enforce any type of term limits like
like you should not we do we've to
enforce them well but not on the
legislative branch we don't afford yeah
so you should not be a senator what do
you think about the judicial branch
should they have term limits because
that's a little weird that gets
political so I understand why they don't
right I understand why they don't
because you don't want a judge to be
politicized politicized they're voted in
they're all for their political views
yeah but I just think it's weird that
there are people whose entire career
senator or I'm a congressman I think you
should have to go out and function in
the world this should it be your entire
career yeah because you should be able
to do it for a certain span of time six
eight years or whatever it is and then
get out of there because otherwise these
power factions develop just corruption
forever make it a lot harder what if
someone's really good at it well then
there should be maybe a special
exception where they'd have a referendum
and they say we want to keep it who's
really good at it I mean we can figure
out how to get to that we could figure
out against Mars I mean is we should be
able to figure out a good a better an
addenda like to make our governing
system we gotta got to recycle more
people in there we can't have people in
there forever but the thing is with
America because people always want to
want to compare America to New Zealand
say Oh New Zealand change the gun was
like that because they have five million
people oh yeah how many people and so
many yeah can't do it so this is a
Eurasian yeah no serious person I think
expects America default you mean the
country of my uncle made a good point
the country's become somewhat uncover
noble because it you know now you had it
show there's so many people there's 300
million people I think so we culture so
many cultures so many people how does
the 350 a fish stick can you Ben's
parents comedies going great by the way
yeah yo Ben's actually doing [ __ ]
great means making money with his socks
on yeah 327 Ben's doing great this is
the future better it's doing great yeah
and you've teamed that just Gordon right
now you're with the hottest [ __ ]
commodity this got Joe Rogan on [ __ ]
speed he's gonna be nominated who's
gonna be there he's gonna quote the
presidential debate he did there there's
a whole big petition for right now do it
wants to do it because if should we hunt
with bows or guns shouldn't be a
question yeah here's what here's what it
would be I think would be years I think
they would have to give him a leeway to
do with the way he wants to do it right
which is not do these little one to two
minutes sound you should also limit the
pictures of elk and holla
a nose won't eat me for what if I can
get on his part the way to do the love
you Joe Rogan but it's a credit
assignment what he puts on Instagram
that's the way to go I'm the biggest
[ __ ] in this [ __ ] room
[ __ ] you know what it's the same [ __ ]
photo it looks delicious but it's the
same [ __ ] phone a lot he loves it and
he'd ski you know listen he hunts it he
eats it he cooks it is healthy I mean
this is nothing but love and respect for
Joe Rogan yeah I think that he's great
you'd be a great interviewer if they
allowed him to do it the way he wants to
do it I would you know it would be it's
the only way to really get the masses of
young voters which is what they want to
watch right nobody's gonna watch it when
they have it's too boring for the kids I
think Joe Rogan gonna do it I think Joe
Rogan would agree that it's scary that a
comedian a great comedian who interviews
anyone there's a lot of people turning
to him to listen to do the interview
series that were a problem right now is
is is how [ __ ] low the journalism
industry has steeped right we got these
journalism journalists with their own
Twitter accounts twitting tweeting out
digs it's like I just saw this [ __ ]
woman from Politico doing a big story on
Giuliani keep it about Giuliani she
tweets about the Giuliani's 20 year old
assistant who did get up by the way
who's hot taking a picture with the
president it's like you don't have any
respect for that that 20 year olds
family crime she's the assistant
how is she part of the story right she
part of your story I have no it's not
I've never so back for journalists
because they don't exist I mean there's
a ton of them in the country look at
what we do on the history I mean Yanis
will write quotes from the new special
why not is not the best [ __ ] BOK
around the world
if Jenni's Plate special is the bet I
love hilarious but that special I didn't
even know if it was stand-up right just
being honest right now I don't know what
the [ __ ] it was people writing about
anything all that out
leaving the rock example we know what a
piss off slang yeah just can we edit
that out I mean she's very very naughty
yeah it's a world where yeah they're
telling me that what was it 20 minutes
and then another 40 minutes of
interviews with her family
yeah I mean and then you tell me it's
great it's like I'm confused by it yeah
dick she's very very vocally people that
are writing about the people that are
writing about comedy are they really
prefer comedians and well let it out
here's the thing there's nothing gets
edited out you gotta edit that out
Jenny Slade's putting you in her [ __ ]
Amazon what do you mean - if you're
behind she hates me just she wants you
delivering pizzas
I think she's funny let me tell you what
she wants you let me tell you what would
happen if you were to party in the hills
and her and John Mulaney yeah she would
walk up to you and hand you a glass of
wine and keep walking
so let's get that [ __ ] straight right
away
the other thing is this the people
writing about comedy right now are
already better from a perspective of
what comedians either would have dated
be in high school or wouldn't have
thrown me in a locker right that's what
it is right there's no there's no
healthy human being writing about comedy
I don't care who we are right it's just
that Jason cinnamon at the Times wishes
he was reviewing theater his mom was a
bigwig in theater and was great right
Joyce in a manner for whatever she had a
whole theatre company he's reviewing
comedy with your base theater right
cloud Matt right who's a sweet girl but
crazy I've offered to have her come on
the podcast she won't come on the
podcast cuz she gets scared - I guess
leave her apartment yeah okay
and Seth Simon's is like the
personification of ringworm yeah not
even real there's other marlo stearns
right gqu they're not real to try to
make GQ woke yes Jane Mayer
Seymour hurt there's a few [ __ ] real
people that are actual tres leches Chris
Hedges that went to a war and he said
you know is you know Chris Hedges this
isn't every moment of joy has been
drained from his body which is what a
real journalist should be yeah um yeah
you're absolutely 100% stone-cold
correct I just want to do it all over
again I went to the New York I'm saying
is if you're writing about the comedy
scene you're basically in the open mic
scene of journalism yeah
you're not even open mind whatever it is
I went to the Nutcracker the other day
and I saw all these little families in
suits at all live in places like
Scarsdale yep and Bronxville and the
east side and the west side and I said I
just want to do it all over again where
my family just really pushed me to just
get into a better real real good college
I've just been would have been an elite
guy that's just I just want to have a
slate gray suit and I just want to just
have a nice you know little little
brownstone and that that's my fantasy
life is to just do it all over again
like this is what I would tell you cuz
you're great dad
steer the ship as much as you can
because the boomers didn't steer the
ship there were like just go to college
doesn't matter what college figure it
out
it'll be great enjoy it we got a good
Community College you'll go that you'll
do it they didn't steer the ship steer
the ship steer it when she starts to get
like 9 10 you really start steering that
ship and by the time kids are [ __ ]
right now by the time they're like 17
right because nobody put the work in
from the jump to get them where they
could be or say brinson saying be a
tiger mom you got to be that why are the
Asians you wouldn't have a podcast
producer if there was Tiger moms that's
true mr. and said go dude go live your
dream he moved in LA no he's sitting on
listen couch there's always making like
there's always gonna be enough runoff in
the world do you understand for people
like me there's always gonna be enough
damage people like me yeah and people
like him that will find each other in it
the house of pies in LA which is where
the gay kids like me and Chris will find
each other 100% but for everybody else
for those traditional people make sure
your [ __ ] kids are on a track in high
sounds like social engineering knowing a
little strike against you gotta
engineered them from the familial point
what team are you on are you on the left
or right I'm on the career yeah I'm on
the team of I just love you why are you
Randy against these [ __ ] tease you
know these Asians and Russian guys
hiding their money from communists holy
what happens is they want to avoid taxes
cuz that's where you have Acacio Cortez
this is
you have these extremes right is because
the [ __ ] the center has clap I agree
with you and that's the problem I so you
can't it's all action and reaction so if
you just please for one second so nobody
gets the wrong idea yeah can you please
just tell me what you said the other
night last night cuz it was beautifully
beautifully beautifully described yeah
and crafted in X but with the trans
thing with the trans thing let me test
with this nobody's right about anything
at 3:00 a.m. on Twitter yeah yeah yeah
but the captures it and just like you
know as much as a Castro Cortez you know
it looks like shades white people it's
what she [ __ ] as much as Yanis tweets
about it's what he jerks off to its
transpose this is what it is supported
Transpo I know I love trans people
though that you're attracted to them I'm
attracted to them if they're hot if you
look like a girl what the real thing I
wasn't about it I keep telling his wife
I'm like you're the perfect girl from
you just need a dip my sexual tastes are
much like the Turkish Sultan's right I'm
a Turkish sultan yeah I like to yeah
your name is on the orientation is women
but if it looked if it looks like a guy
if it looks like a girl I'm fooled right
fool me and credit to you well here's
what I was saying about the trance I was
saying that there's there's it's not
even trans people it's not day-to-day
trans people you meet it's not gay
people to care about redefining society
in this way however what it really is is
there's you know radical groups of
people that want power and they want to
redefine all of society and they look
for a way to do it then look for an
entrance point right they're like how
can we how can we start this process how
do we get in so they pick issues like
the trans issue because they can't just
come out and say give me all your money
you can't come out and say give me all
your money and by the way we don't think
you should have any speech rights we
don't think you should be able to talk
about anything so what they do is they
come in to an issue that most people can
understand and say yeah well we want to
be kind we don't want to be cruel we
want to be welcoming and accepting to
people so what they do is they allow
this transition to become their main
issue and then they try to move the ball
down the field far enough show that they
really limit the scope of what you can
discuss and talk about in that one and
then by the way doesn't stop there
ends with we want 80% of your income and
you're not allowed to say anything right
and that's an old story and that's an
old story you see it you see it in
Venezuela because you've seen it with
Che Guevara all your money and you don't
have a family and there's no bulwark
against the state right we'd come in and
we run everything we engineer you we
want to control you that is it's the
same way on the other side with the far
right they want to put choosing camps
right they want it they wanna they want
gay people trans people to be Marg Allah
because they want to enforce medieval
Christianity as a tool of societal
control that's what it is it's just a
bunch of people that want control and I
just need a pool in the Hollywood Hills
right that's all I want I just want a
vantage point to watch it burn no but I
think it's I think it's very important
for for people yeah we listen to this or
anywhere and this is why I go crazy
through the morning to hold the line of
reality because that is the center the
center is going hey I support trans
people trans people is a beautiful
modern thing but let's not let's not
let's not throw caution to [ __ ]
reality I mean it's it's a it's a
consequence of modernity I mean they
take blockers they take estrogen or
testosterone and that's great and they
identify because they're the brain is is
that way that orientation in their brain
is that way and they identify that way
and they want to take that to fruition
but you know they are trans women
they're not women because if they're not
if they're women what are women so
because logically if you're saying trans
women or women then that means all women
are trans yeah and they're not so it's
like if you're insinuating that that
trans women aren't trans women then
you're almost implying something's wrong
with being a trend which is which
there's trying to get rid of Trance so
what they're trying to do yeah is just
trying to get rid of the step between
they want you to separate sex and gender
yeah that's what that's what I think
where the confusion comes in they want
you to say your biological sex is
different than what your gender is
that's what they're trying to also want
to say that they also want to say this
but your gender you can choose but
you're said they want to say this the
gender itself entirely is it construct
in a result of a suicide that's not true
you can't right that's
well your intention no is not true and
they don't kicks partnerpartner' truth
what it acts are like ninety [ __ ] right
we are done with fares nobody in the
Trump rally gives a [ __ ] about facts
they go keep building the wall there's
not one brick of the wall they don't
care right facts mean nothing to them he
went and he said I'm gonna clean up Wall
Street we're gonna eliminate the carried
interest loophole we're gonna [ __ ]
reign those guys and he didn't do any of
that by the way we're worth you know
what he did this crisis will be another
cry I mean we've done nothing to
insulate ourselves from the next
financial crash and what I'm about to
say I want your opinion on what Trump
did fix LaGuardia Airport I just want to
say that there's an artichoke eats in
there and it's a one wing of the Airport
policy cops yeah but it's one part is
nice a lot of mean I find a Jeff cat
under LaGuardia LaGuardia can't handle
the planes I use music Robin find a JFK
yeah so here's my question
it's obvious to everybody at this point
who has any sense that the conversation
has been hijacked yeah by the extreme
right and the extreme left sensible
people know that that's bad yes I think
the majority is still sense as sensible
so but the the conversation has been
hijacked by these two minorities of
fanatics now when you look back at
history you look back at World War one
you look back at World War two you see
at the outset of World War one radio was
invented so there was this great tool to
now galvanize and propagate to the
masses that that mobilized and was used
as an apparatus to accelerate a world
war then you see TV was invented around
world war two you see the same thing
happened with TV where the Germans used
it especially and so did the Americans
as a tool to mobilize etc same thing as
what I said before now we have the
Internet the third great invention for
communication the same thing seems to be
happening where it is being used to
galvanize these extreme points of view
the inevitable being another world war
your thoughts sir yeah well I think when
you look at who that war is gonna be
with I think
are gonna happen because of what I'm
saying
inevitable you of it based on those two
examples but I think the mutually
assured destruction of the nukes keeps
us from that I think not even close well
it was a borrowed [ __ ] from The
Breakfast Club I'm not even close bud I
would say this people are [ __ ] stupid
I would say this everybody has prepend
of guns preparing for war with China I
mean we have been for a long time there
gonna be a proxy war cuz the Chinese are
putting these Muslim poor Muslim kids in
[ __ ] concentration camps right now
there's a whole indigenous group these
Chinese are so [ __ ] godless yeah I
don't mean that in a bad way right I'm
getting carried away here I don't mean
everyone yeah maybe this you got it out
but no because I'm agnostic but I'm just
saying like something very nefarious is
happening over there where there is this
sort of you see the beginnings of like
these concentration camps happening yeah
and it's happening yeah and this is
something we saw happen in the 40s and
it's like the internet is just swelling
everyone it's bringing out the lowest
common denominator of people yeah listen
my father who has I'm not lying I think
he got through ninth grade my dad you
know was doing you know really didn't
set himself up at all not the brightest
guy in the world but he's had some hot
days at the horse tracks that some hot
days on track and my mother was [ __ ]
hot when she was young and he scooped
her up she was a friend but what he said
I'll never forget this 2009 I started
comedy whatever Twitter comes out we're
talking and my dad goes you see this new
thing there's Twitter thing he's like do
you have one and I was like no I gotta
get one though you know all comedians
happen he goes it's gonna be a big
mistake for the people in the country
and I was like why is that cuz not
everyone's supposed to be heard from
yeah everybody's supposed to have a
voice she does think about think about
how much [ __ ] happens if you know if you
get up in front of a crowded cafeteria
but he's talking nobody's listening he
said so this is gonna be the biggest
problem our country ever had as his
Twitter [ __ ] and he's kind of not
long-run absolutely rancid guy who's as
a 9th grade education yeah I had a
mentor in college professor Smith one of
the most wisest people I've ever had at
American the American University where I
was educated my alma mater which is
Latin for all the guys eaten kids on
Epstein's Islands no it was now but
the one thing he'd say I'll never forget
he says he says comfort corrupts yeah
that's what it is yeah it's inevitable
doesn't matter what your moral were
brought up you have to constantly guard
yourself against the corruption of
comforts and people just don't have the
energy of the willpower to consistently
check in on that so what I'm basically
saying is we were designed to fail hmm
we're at the end we've climbed up the
mountain but we are Sisyphus the rock
will fall on us we've made it to the end
we're not going to another solar system
we're not going to another [ __ ]
habitable planet in the habitable
planets are 300 million light years away
we're sucking all the resources out of
the earth and it's gonna shuffle things
around in a way that that's gonna hurt
us because nature does not like
imbalance and that's just written it's
fate we're going to go away you know
locker roaches and rats are what evolved
now I feel like someone there's an
island bar some island paradise we don't
know exists and somebody's saying that
exact thing and Geoffrey app sees you
sitting there with a glass of rum going
life will find a way show me a body
right who knows there's another I'm sure
there's you know that's the other thing
we'll just never know yeah that's you
think that's what conspiracies are
ultimately frustrating and they just
don't lead anywhere cuz you're never
gonna know unless you're on the inside
right people don't know anything about
comedy I always explains to ban him like
nobody knows with the green room of the
store is Lyle of the cellar and by the
way we all know what it's like and we're
all like huh why would you want to know
but here's the thing because to them
it's magic
to them it's Magic's not it's not of
course everyone sitting in silo we know
yeah but we know yeah now there's two
ways to experience anything from the
outside of the inside both have their
benefits being on the inside you know
what it really is being on the outside
you have your idea of what it really is
being on the inside you have no more
illusions about what it is on the
outside you have all illusions about
what it is they both have their benefits
it's it when you when you look at this
stuff so much of there's so many of the
decisions that are being made in our
world being made at third
thousand feet we just don't know what's
going on we can't we can make jokes we
can read books we can have ideas but we
don't really know the thought process or
what goes into this and our own little
corner of the world which is which is
entertainment you know most people look
at the entertainment business and for
you know for whatever reason they think
you have an idea of how it works and
they just all and you could see an
entertainment especially in New York or
LA but you know I can comment on New
York I live here even the things that
are massive you know a year ago me too
massive movement I was at Yanis is by
the way massive movement on the island
of Manhattan you go to Long Island you
go on me to wine oh that sounds just
gonna say when I was at when I was at
Jana sue she rushed right when I when I
was at Yanis is engagement party I was
talking to one of one of his wife's
lovely friends trying to have sex with
her right and she's a lot of Republicans
a Long Island schoolteacher and I said
something I said I was talking about all
my favorite comedian is Louie and I was
like wow you don't see a lot of women
saying that these days because of the me
to stuff she's like what's that and I
said what do you mean what said that she
started asking her friends and she goes
what's the meet to what did Louis do and
this was months months after yeah you
know whatever and you're like what and
it's like yeah because most people don't
care even Louis himself I heard him
speaking even though he himself had said
you know the beginning of last year he
would be on the train and people would
be talking about you know commenting oh
you [ __ ] pig your rapist will [ __ ]
that's that's crazy it's not accused of
any of that right but now because of all
how things go in cycles or whatever it
now people like he'll be on the train
and he said people be like oh you know
what happened he was unfortunate I can't
believe society treats you this way I'm
coming your show and he's bad he's gonna
be back selling tickets again because
it's all just ease of movement he's
closing what do you think cuz there's an
engine question about Louie how do you
think he you know he's on a theater tour
now well no he's doing the date and
funnybone okay so he's not doing
theaters not yet but he can do them it's
just it's just he's gotta wait til some
of this sting comes out of you know the
theaters not wanting to be seen booking
him he could sell he could sell it
Madison Square Garden right now but
absolutely people need to grow up we
need to become adults again yeah we're
living in this period of extended youth
yeah everyone's acting like a child so
how does that happen that was right a
child
the amenities of modernity but we have a
notion of comfort I know but how do you
how do you how if you tuned into the Tim
Dylan [ __ ] show let's say you like
your [ __ ] medicine like a [ __ ] man
you all know that's how you change if
you had the if you literally I'm giving
you the reins right now you're the
president of the United States
yes let's let's first for the Chinese
are going back into internment camp
cause if you're the president I'm your
first lady yeah you are so that's a
George people joke instead of before you
in turn the Chinese which I'm not
necessarily gets yeah well fort some
condos what do you do what do you have a
big speech you go out and tell everybody
they're in trouble well what do you
literally do yeah I start with some sort
of speech about nature yes sir IIIi want
to remind people that being detached
from the reality of nature is a luxury
but an illusion how do you think that
plays in an Applebee's in a Dulce well
I'm going in with armed guns
oh so you're watching and you're
agreeing that's not a choice right no
you said I'm going to president first
yeah I'm doing a hostile takeover it to
do right when I get in yeah I'm making
an alignment with the I'm making I'm
doing it like Batman I'm taking full
power but I'm giving it away at the end
right yes I'm a principal guy I like
that I'm a great kid I like that a COO
and then you give a nice speech about
nature yeah my speeches like I want you
to go I want you to go look at this
thing that we're part of right very easy
to get detached because of the amenities
of modernity the comforts provide you
this illusion that we're not part of
nature the laws of nature need to be
obeyed and our principles and our laws
of governance need to be in accordance
with nature we're a little out of whack
everyone's gotten a little spoiled we
need a little perspective here's why and
here's what I'm basing my perspective on
it's called nature right worship what
you want think what you want but this is
a system that was created based in
nature people are free for the pursuit
of happiness not guaranteed there's no
such thing as equality
there's equality under the law right men
and women are not the same right can be
the same but that's the exception not
the rule men compete over here women
compete over here eventually hopefully
I'm so pro trans trans people should
compete over here and that's what it is
we're not equal it's not fair for a
woman who transitioned a year to go to
be competing against girls and
dominating that's not fair
trans women or trans women and that's a
beautiful thing it doesn't mean they're
women okay so call it what you want I'll
give you control the semantics but stop
trying to say they're the same cuz
they're not because then they start
competing in the same leagues and that's
not fair it also is not fair to women
because it defines that out of existence
that's not fair it's anti-feminist so I
start with a couple of points like that
and then I bring out the guns and kill
whoever disagree I guess that I would
say we're not changing a thing but
everybody's getting a coupon for a
Popeye's chicken sandwich Wow go to
cruise that's why you're gonna be my
secretary of [ __ ] Bulls everybody
could get cruise cuz I get right out and
I go listen hey boomers
here's reality we could try to remake
society in the image of nature or we
could all get on a big boat with a
24-hour buffet and go to a little island
in Mexico where slaves will bring you
pina coladas and they're just gonna go
hey Saget where's the boat people find
you guys what is history hyenas where
the Tim Dylan the great Tim Dylan is is
a friend of whatever he's in town we
want a montage we go by the way we need
to redo the podcast game right here in
New York City where everything starts
yes this episode is available on our
joint patreon by the lioness comm
patreon.com slash Bay Ridge Boys and on
paper the motion is that come New York
it's a tired old [ __ ] and I'll tell you
right now the comedy scene here I love
all you guys it's uh it's it it just
limping along we'll be in Los Angeles
turns out to the citrus limping along
right now because it's in love with the
past yes it's in love with the past you
forgetting a little tool we have in our
back pocket called Fuhrer Andrew Schultz
I was amongst uh you know we're
following the guidance and the tutelage
of our Fuhrer Andrew Schultz if you go
to patreon.com/scishow sprite now the
million-dollar tier will get you the
secret Tim Dylan episode number record
you want to pay a million dollars we're
gonna put out the episode the meet
crystianna's recorded 1 mil we just went
a little wild yeah I had 1 million
dollars we split it with you five
hundred three ways to true if you're
listening we're talking to you James
Altucher this is for you I'm doing his
prices another job and I am this is not
a joke we are putting up for $1,000,000
arrabal Tim Dylan episode the infamous
Tim Dunn episode for $1,000,000 on
patreon.com slash $1 patreon.com you can
hear us go a little wild yeah
think about what we won't put out
because we put out a lot of stuff so I
don't want this going out I know nobody
wants anything going out if y'all had
his way with just podcast nothing but
going yeah yeah but the reality is you
know this is going out you know what
what do you think you think Jenny
Slade's calling you up to [ __ ] collab
now Jenny slate would be like hey can
you get me like a chicken parmesan here
up yes I think she's very funny by the
way I just think she thinks you're a
postman yeah so I love her too we all
love her and she walk over at dead
bodies I respect the hell out and God
bless her she's doing great and you know
it is what it is I there is no loyalty
here's the deal when the Gillis thing
happened and you had everybody that
didn't even know Shane thrown him under
the brunt of the boss yeah there was no
loyalty months comics now that sadness
me I don't like that that's the case but
that is the [ __ ] case anybody was
talking about loyalty or a short
efficient honor codes they're all full
of [ __ ] it's just not true
mm-hmm everybody kind of throws
everybody else under the bus and so far
I was one of the only people defending
shame you were and by the way I'm
including his close friends weren't
defending him so the reality of the
situation is it just is here's all you
need to know about entertainment and
where it's at and where the world is
that here's what you need to know Shane
Gillis okay was dropped by his agents
jussie Smollett was not correct that's
all you need to know please know where
you are
who used police resources you
investigate a bogus hate crime and by
the way there were two guys in there had
been picked up for some drunk whatever
jerseys Mallette probably would have
fingered them and they would have been
in jail like yup - and it said guys so a
truly evil human being uh it was not
dropped by UTI but but Shane was so
that's where we're at and a lot of
comedians went to go speak out about how
inappropriate Shane was when they had
said things that were absolutely worse
radition is just a hypocritical group of
people and anytime I hear that word
loyalty from a manager from an age from
anybody i I couldn't want to get further
away from because it's it ain't true but
it's not aware of it this jig is up it's
also it's also crazy to think that what
we just did on this podcast is anything
more than entertainment right you do
understand we're professional comedians
if there's a journalist listening to
this right now
you do understand that we're comedians
we don't game by the way there there's
no journalist listen ya [ __ ] idiot is
who thinks he writes for a career maybe
listening to this to hold our feet to
the fire for anything that we're saying
this is a podcast by comedians we are
entertainers we don't hold any power any
positions of power and I don't seek it
we're seeking to entertain you to give
you something to do while you're killing
time for dying right here you're waiting
to die and we're making that a little
less painful by bonnie was some [ __ ]
entertainment and that's where it is yes
I'm not running for public office or
anything I say on this podcast but we
were joking it's entertainment it's like
you're watching it's a character piece
I'm running for public office by the way
because I truly believe now why not I
think why not why not why not I mean
look if we're gonna just if it's all
over anyway I will go right I know
exactly where I'm gonna go it's a little
district called
Long Island New York because I know what
to say to win yeah I will say we are we
are going to have a vote in a bar we're
gonna vote if we could smoke in the bar
yeah that's it yeah
we are gonna worry about the employees
of the bar are having you inhale
secondhand smoke they should have made
better choices
am I right Bob you'll be yeah rack the
rallies on 9/11 M okay he's in bail more
yeah 9/11 9/11 you get to commit one
hate crime and not by the purge yes a
nonviolent hate crime the 9/11 you could
you could put yo you know you could you
could rip someone's hijab off it can't
be violent done or you could spray a
swastika on a McDonald's whatever it is
you get to do one nonviolent hate crime
at 9/11 this is how I'm gonna get
elected in Long Island furthermore D
wheeze the new D we law is if you can
state your full name first middle and
last and it matches your ID you are not
too drunk to drive you're absolutely
fine got it right back in that car and
you do what you need to do good we can't
be Precious about worrying about life
and every single person no no the other
thing is there's gotta be an
acknowledgment and Long Island people
understand it's justice just gotta be an
acknowledgement that on the Long Island
Rail Road there are no laws so the laws
of man do not come into the Long Island
Railroad when those doors closed we're
back to the Coliseum and ancient Rome
yeah blood first blood yeah is the
please the law of the land
yep that's it I love it and that's I'm
gonna write you got my vote go to
history hyenas support their patron on
Tim Dylan show Tim Dylan comedy calm
dates coming up McGoo bees Austin Texas
at cap city fun stuff coming up in
Toronto House of comedy in Minneapolis
Arizona blah blah blah a lot of fun
we're up in Vancouver where Toronto Tim
Villa comedy calm all those links all
those tickets fun stuff mega McCain
short coming thanks to everybody who
bought her other shirt we're designing a
mega contra it might take a while and
it's interesting somebody's with her the
other night and she's not a fan she did
not like that I called her fat by the
way I said so many worse things well
then you don't what are you gonna do
back to the history hyenas and uh
goodbye